[Music]
now this is an interesting thought what
if king kong was in jurassic park of the
latter jurassic world the eighth wonder
of the world in an island full of
dinosaurs sounds a bit familiar doesn't
it cause he always has been in islands
full of dinos skull island in many
iterations including the original was a
land loss in time where the ancient life
forms did not go extinct but managed to
survive live on and even evolve and
along with them were other deadly
creatures including the mega primate we
all know and love so here in this video
we will assess the version of kong who
will be in jurassic world slash park and
how he would fare against the indian
dino clones and whether he will still be
king or not
so firstly we will have to take a look
at which version of king kong that we
should focus on of course the monster
verse kong would be an overkill even the
2017 version would be too big if
compared to even the biggest dinosaurs
like the brachiosaurus or the
mossosaurus the biggest land dyno the
brachio would only be a third of his
height so the monster versus titanos
kong is out of the question the version
from king kong vs godzilla would also be
too big the one from 1962 and the latest
version from the monster verse so let's
take the 2005 version this kong is 18
feet tall on all fours and 25 feet tall
when standing by pedal and already has
quite an experience with dinosaurs in
his version of skull island
okay now that we have chosen the correct
kong for the job let's see if the island
would be a good habitat for him and if
he was there what would be the location
of his hideout so as most of us know
jurassic park and the latter jurassic
world was built on an island in the
tropics very much like skull island but
more accessible to humans
isla nubla and isla sauna are two
islands west of costa rica the bigger
one sauna is filled with mountainous
ridges and different types of ecological
niches so is nubla both of them are very
similar to skull island but the only
difference is the size of the place
while skull island is generally accepted
to be around 1 000 square kilometers in
size or 386 square miles island new blur
is only 77 square kilometers or 30
square miles in size
so much room for confrontation and so
less space for survival
we should also know what dinosaurs would
be on the island well during the
jurassic world era there were around 50
clone dinosaur species in the island and
many of them were also taken and
transported from isla sona which also is
known as site b to nubla site a where
the park was created not all the species
that were cloned were dinos
some were also related species like the
flying pterosaurs and the marine
mausosol
the big sauropods will include the
brachiosaurus and the apatosaurus there
will also be ceratopsians like the
triceratops the nasutoceratops and the
xenoceratops there are also armored
ankylosaurus stegosauruses and large at
montosaurus as well as parasol loafers
aside from these herbivores there will
also be large medium and small sized
carnivores
these carnivorous dinosaurs are in a way
comparable to the skull island dinos the
pack predators like the velociraptors
would be synonymous with the venator
source of the 2005 movie but there are
way more species of large carnivores in
jurassic world than in skull island
while we only saw the vastatosaurus rex
in the king kong movie in the jurassic
franchise however there are t-rex
then there are also the spinosaurs the
indominus rex which are all comparable
and worthy predators that can kill an
individual like kong in certain
instances and even medium-sized ones
like the allosaurus the situ mimus the
baryonyx the carnotaurus the
steretosaurus and the scorpius rex just
to name a few could prey on younger
gongs so with many other carnivores
would gong stand a chance here
do you know that we should know what his
place is in the food chain
so the mega primatus kong is an
omnivorous creature that ate a wide
variety of foods like bamboo mammals
plants termites insects fish birds eggs
and fruits they sometimes even eat meat
from both large and small mammals and
even dinosaurs
and also carcasses but they never
usually eat humans or other apes
kongs appear to possess intelligence
comparable to those of ordinary apes
although some of their movements suggest
a superior intelligence very much
comparable to us humans
he definitely would not be an apex
predator because that is against his
biology but he will still hold a high
rank in the chain maybe slightly
independent of the eat and be eaten
system as he could very well hold his
own against large predators and still
won't hunt them down for food kind of
like us humans in a way
okay so now that we have established his
spot in the food chain we shall look
into where he would be geographically
his hide outlets say
if we look at the island it's the new
bla we can clearly see different types
of landscapes there are lush jungles
vast grasslands swamps and even
mountainous parts it has mountainous
cliffs near the coastline
but kong usually prefers to be in the
center of the island
so the most probable location for his
nest or den would be near the volcano
which would put him close to the raptor
blue's nest and the indominus pada
again isla nubla is very small in
comparison to skull island which would
put the giant ape in proximity to many
other large carnivores and now we shall
discuss how he would fare against such
dinosaurs
what if he battle a t-rex an indominus
rex or a spinosaurus
well let's look at kong's abilities
first kong's brute strength was
particularly impressive a fully grown
comb can easily win over an average
v-rex however the largest v-rex would
have been a formidable opponent mega
primatus kong was capable of lifting a
v-rex off the ground as well as throwing
flipping and pinning the massive
predator corn was capable of fighting of
three v rexes all at once but he was a
rare specimen with years of expertise
mega private skong had the benefit of
intelligence incredible dexterity with
gripping hands and feet and primitive
weaponry kong's combat skills include
grappling renting wrestling punching and
biting he is an incredible climber and
despite his size he was remarkably agile
so in order to know if kong could be
really the king of the island we have to
compare this large creature with the
large carnivores of jurassic world which
would also be comparable to the vrx of
skull island the vasatosaurus is 45 to
50 feet long and has incredibly thick
skin which has osteoderms like
crocodiles and a sweet smile full of
jagged teeth they were more evolved
versions of the t-rex and since kong
could beat one of them a t-rex would
also follow the same fate
a pair of them like the buck and the doe
from the second movie if fighting
together could eventually overpower the
great ape but then again kong has fought
off three v-rexes all at once
but was on the losing side only winning
because he had the terrain to his
advantage so in the worst possible
scenario kong would be heavily injured
and would manage to escape from the two
t-rexes a single one however would have
its mouth snap
so what about the spinosaurus and the
indominus rex
both these two dinosaurs have been seen
to overpower a t-rex in separate battles
and since kong could do the same this
would put them all in the same level
playing field honestly speaking the
spinosaurus with its huge sail its size
and long forums would be a very
dangerous opponent to kong again this
comes to the terrain in the forest kong
will clearly come out as the winner and
the spinosaurus would have
to suffer from a serious case of being
dead
in the grasslands the bell could go
either way but in the swarms and near
water bodies spinosaurus will have the
upper hand and kong would drown the
spinal will be as big as the biggest
v-rex and this will be a problem for
kong since there would be a massive size
difference
and lastly the indominus rex if this
creature was on the island the entire
ecosystem would be at risk let's just
say that the teeth of the indominus rex
are contagious and will just spread like
wildfire it would kill for sport and
eventually have already killed the t-rex
and maybe the spinosaurus it is after
all the most powerful land predator on
the island slightly having an advantage
over the spino due to its high
intelligence and wide array of abilities
like active camouflage
and an insatiable bloodlust kong will
have a big problem in his hands if the
indominus rex was living together with
him it could stop the big ape and kong
wouldn't know it was there until the
last moment like boo i'm
how the battle would go is up to debate
let's just say that the irex is the one
existential threat to the giant ape
anyway with that we come to the end of
it so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well to be a
part of the mind cue family but most of
all smash that bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one take care fam